an enormous amount of trouble in the
world especially at work and in
relationships is caused by a peculiar
phenomenon of our minds a tendency to be
as we put it out of touch with our
feelings when we first meet this idea it
sounds strange and even a bit insulting
how could we not know what we are
feeling of course we look from the
outside like unified beings we carry one
name and sit in a compact physical
container the distances between
different parts of us aren't so great
how then could we be so multiple as to
have secrets from ourselves
but in reality there are at least two
distinct parts to mental life a feeling
self and an observer self sometimes the
two are utterly aligned someone asked us
what we feel like eating and the
communication between the two selves is
clear and immediate we don't even notice
a lag we simply answer salmon and
avocado at other points it's far
trickier we're sitting on the sofa at
home after a long day at work and are
under the impression that we feel quite
calm but suddenly an apparently minor
remark from our partner arouses us to
deep irritation we stand up and start
shouting about the unfairness of a host
of issues we hadn't until just then you
know where we even felt strongly about
soon we've got a crisis on our hands why
is it so hard for the observing self to
report accurately on feelings firstly
because we're afflicted by so many
background ideas about the
unacceptability of particular feelings
across childhood we have instilled in us
so subtly we don't even notice strong
notions about what are and are not
permissible things to experience
traditionally this might have meant that
boys were not allowed to acknowledge
that they felt like crying or that girls
weren't allowed to entertain certain
kinds of ambitions for fear of being
unladylike we might not have such
obviously naive prohibitions today but
other equally powerful ones have taken
their place
we may have picked up covert but
forceful indications that no decent
person no one loved by their parents at
least could be enthusiastic about making
money or unable to cope at work tempted
by an affair or still upset over a
breakup three years ago furthermore
despite the apparently sexually
liberated spirit of the times the lion's
share of our sexual impulses remains
impossible to avow there is still a
great deal when not meant to feel in
order to fit that most desirable of
categories a good boy or good girl
when difficult feelings do threaten to
emerge the observing self typically
takes fright and looks away rather than
produce an honest account of feelings it
may go numb or try to file a report
that's more acceptable than true I'm
feeling very tired instead of I'm
feeling you've let me down I'm depressed
rather than I'm furious that's
absolutely disgusting rather than I'm
strangely turned on our problems are
compounded by the way that many powerful
feelings especially of upset Envy and
frustration can get kicked into action
by apparently very trivial and seemingly
nonsensical things in the outside world
for example we might be thrown into
paroxysm zuv Envy we find no room to
confess to when a friend mentions that a
mutual acquaintance has been promoted or
a partner may look away for three and a
half seconds before we've ended an
explanation about how a tricky meeting
at work went and we experienced seething
indignation and wounded pride that we
haven't got our lovers full attention
but we say nothing because to own up too
many feelings of upset involves
acknowledging a humiliating degree of
fragility yet feelings that haven't been
reported don't and can't go away they
linger and spread their energy randomly
to neighboring issues envy comes out as
spite anger over inattention comes out
as a remark that the partner is looking
rather at at the moment though of course
by the time that urge has manifested
itself as aggression any chances of
being comforted or clearly over feelings
we haven't got a handle on wreak havoc
they buckle and strain the system we
developed pernicious tics of facial
twitch impotence and incapacity to work
alcoholism a compulsion to look at porn
most so-call addictions are at heart
symptoms of insistent difficult feelings
that we haven't found any better way to
address how then might we come to be
more skilled observers and
correspondence of our feelings reading
they have rather a large role to play a
great writer is ideally someone uncommon
ly patient about the curious less
discussed apparently weirder things that
float around in the human head another
move is to ensure that we've allocated a
lot of time to self observation it can
look rather self-indulgent to ask for a
few hours in the evening in which
there's nothing more apparently
demanding to do than sit and stare out
of the window or around the bedroom with
a patent pen on one's lap these
so-called idle moments are when the
observing self can finally catch up with
feelings that might have been too shy
ashamed or harassed to emerge in the
rest of the day they are like church
bells we can make out only in the
evening when the city traffic has died
down
failing to do this can among other
things
our chances of getting to sleep insomnia
is the feeling selves revenge for all
the thoughts that haven't been properly
catalogued in the day understanding the
serious danger of a gap opening up
between what we feel and what we're
aware of brings another major benefit we
grasp that this issue will necessarily
apply to other people too quite often
they'll be saying things which are not
in fact in line with their true feelings
mean things when they're feeling
vulnerable perhaps or arrogant things
when they're feeling small and we'll
identify that it's our duty to forgive
them for not always managing to be
reliable correspondents of their inner
lives it's not really sinister to think
this way of others
it's a kindly move that gives us the
energy to lend a second more
compassionate look and behavior that
might initially have appeared simply
horribly off-putting feelings are
frequently far from wonderful and often
should not be followed but we should
accept that if we ignore deny or
overlook feelings entirely the price
will always be higher and worse they
will exercise a powerful malign
subterranean influence across the whole
one of the two often overlooked but key
arts of living is to learn to devote
ourselves to correctly labeling and
repatriating our own and others orphaned
feelings
you